so
john stuart mill again i put out here on
the board in
his essay utilitarianism he is the
second generation
utilitarian par excellence his dad was a
utilitarian a friend of
bentham's mill was brought up with the
philosophy
and by the time that mill is writing
there's a lot of objections
to this moral theory and a good part of
the first part
of utilitarianism is just trying to
address those and identify those
explicitly
while he's doing that and this is you'll
often see this in philosophy he ends up
adding some new things making some new
movements
and we're really interested in one of
these in particular which is going to
tie in with the
tasting and talk about you know
cultivation scallop
and all that stuff but first let's think
about this so he's addressing criticisms
of bentham's
utilitarian moral theory that people
from other
perspectives are making and i'm
i didn't put all of them on the board
here i just put a few of them
these are some of the most interesting
ones one of the ones that
he talks about is this notion and i
think some of you any of those of you
who are doing
design work would would see it this way
utility means not pleasurable oftentimes
when we say utilitarian
we mean that something is just
serviceable so you know
my otter box for my my iphone right here
is very utilitarian compared to some of
the
fancier more aesthetically pleasing
cases that you guys have for your phones
right what is the purpose of this
it's not to look good right what is this
yeah just protection i mean this is this
is the most solid thing that you can get
and why do i have it because i'm very
klutzy and i would
otherwise destroy my iphone if i didn't
have the sort of thing that that truck
can run over which
they can do so some guys that i knew
actually did an experiment with that
mill says that's actually a mistake in
understanding of utilitarianism um
oftentimes we take utilitaria
the utilitarian approach is getting rid
of all the possible ornaments
not making things entertaining mill
would say
no you missed the point if you said that
because utilitarianism is about what
pain and pleasure
so the more pleasurable you can make
something the better it is
so you know if my again use my phone if
my
phone could look a little nicer it would
have greater utility utility is not
opposed to pleasure utility
is what what leads to pleasure so that's
you know that's
easy enough to get you know take care of
this thing
another uh problem that people brought
up is they said well it's not really
practical to aim at happiness for all
people or most people and this is an
objection that
that had a lot of traction back then but
probably has
less traction now our sentiments when it
comes to this are probably
in many respects reverse to to the
climate that milwaus
was uh writing and arguing
the basic idea was well you know great
so you're going to aim
at making people's lives happier
you know greater balance of pleasure in
their lives most people got to work for
a living problem and
what was work like back in the 18th or
the 17th
the 19th century what do you remember
from your history classes
what was what was work like at the
beginning of the industrial age
for most people yeah
before the transition people would be
outside working like
cotton orange in the fields then started
moving towards uh
yeah so and then he's in england too so
they're they're not going cut but
they're growing
they're doing other agricultural things
they go into these big cities
big cities had terrible sanitation
they stink most of the time noisy
you'd go into these these factories
how what were factories like
fun places send your kids they would
send their kids right
were they like yeah
overcrowded okay overcrowded you got
people jam-packed in there
like like sardines what else were they
safe yeah
dangerous yeah people lose their fingers
their hands
eyes and there wasn't any there wasn't a
lot of you know
worker compensation arrangements or
anything like that that was up to the
employer if they were
a nice guy they might help you out or
help your family out otherwise they'd
say well you're no longer
a worker because you don't have a hand
so see you later
so you know in that sort of environment
you could say well this is not a
very practical point of view that we
should try to make everybody's life
happier you know we should aim at
introducing as much pleasure because
look most people just have to work
and get by and we'll we'll talk about
that a little bit
a little bit later this is the one i'm
really interested in
this is the one that ties in with this
this discussion of food
people said this is a philosophy fit for
pigs this is an objection
that's been made you remember when we
were studying aerostitis and
epicurus aristippus really was
advocating
a philosophy in some ways fit for pigs
because he was all about physical
pleasure right
and think about now you know take away
some of the moral of program and forget
the fact that pigs wallow in
in mod and filth and all that and think
about pigs they're you know
pretty smart animals smarter than your
dogs or cats
um way smarter than horses
you know how you know
how much can a pig actually appreciate
some people keep pigs as pets
don't they do you guys know anybody who
keeps pigs as pets
yeah what is it what is its life
easily trainable they're smart and what
does a pig like to do all day
mostly so they sleep so we do that right
what else do they like to do they enjoy
eating
we enjoy eating what else what else do
we have in common with pigs
we have a lot of things actually you get
down to it
i imagine the pet pig likes getting you
know scratched like a dog or cat
we like that sort of thing too you know
pay people
you know to give us massages you know or
go to the spa and do things right um
we like to lay in the sun they like to
lay in so that's a nice pleasure
um pigs you know they desire sex we
desire sex
you know we could go through the whole
thing the pigs um
let's just drop it down to dogs and cats
the dog the dogs and kids is just
all about eating laying in the sun
or do they have a sense of curiosity
from your experience
do they get into things why do they get
into things
because they enjoy that right that's
that's pleasure do we do that sort of
stuff
yeah we're always like wait what's
around that corner there that's
that's still at an animal level um
so now if we're focusing on these sort
of
things that we share in common with all
the animals maybe this
and we're focusing on pleasures and
pains maybe this is a philosophy fit for
pigs
um you know you didn't say you know fit
for
camels or you know some other lower
thing um epicurus didn't see it that way
what was epicurus's big contribution do
you guys remember
as opposed to aristippus
aerostipus was okay with like you know
say going to a prostitute
and uh you know saying i just want the
pleasure
let's cut out all the chit chat yeah the
energy is really doing well calculated
pleasures
okay well calculated so that uses what
how do you calculate
process what's that like bullet process
you have to think about it
yeah so and the the mere act of thinking
itself can be pleasurable too right
all of you have experience with that
maybe not necessarily with ethics class
or philosophy and that's okay
but with your majors we've talked about
this number of times over the course of
the semester
you've picked your major hopefully it's
something that you're good at something
you actually enjoy doing
you know you picked accounting you like
accounting right
thank goodness for that because you're
going to be doing that for a good
you know 20 years if not 40 years after
you get out of here so i
you know i hope it's something that you
actually like you know
business right uh you like you like
business right
no you should start thinking about
winning whether
whether you're going to do that writing
right you enjoy writing
you enjoy writing too so maybe you
should think about becoming a writer
or a business writer right but you enjoy
writing it's something that you
you do that's not something that pig can
do that's
now we're at a higher order activity
and epicurus pointed this out but every
time that people thought about epicurus
they always sort of like
thought of him as aerostatus and this
has been done throughout the ages
so the epicurean philosophy was supposed
to be you know just about
you know sensual pleasure not about
mental pleasure so mill is trying to
respond to this
and one way that you could respond if
you were bent them you could say well
mental pleasure is just
more pleasurable you know you get more
units of pleasure remember we're always
about measuring pleasures and pains
get more units of pleasure by doing
mental activity and
that would have been one way to go um
and bentham himself seems to have had
something like that in mind
but maybe that's not the the best
strategy to take
because maybe that's not capturing
something that's really essential about
us human beings
so what mills us can i just interject
absolutely so i had sometimes in my
class if you guys have done the hedonic
calculus
i'll i'll make it like uh i'll have the
students go through it and then
um you know pick something that's say
more sensual i always call it the sex
dress and rock and roll problem but
yeah so yeah so i would say like you
know uh go through the hedonic
calculus and uh figure out how much
pleasure you would get from say having a
glass of wine or going to a concert or
something like that and we run through
all the numbers the kids have to do the
seven criteria
yeah and then i'll have a uh you know do
the same thing for reading bentham
yeah and then you know inevitably
inevitably
uh you know if you're according to
philosophy you should go have a beer
instead of read his book right and so
yeah actually it'll be kind of an
interesting thing would be
so you guys have read that them and
you've read mill if you were stuck
having to read one of them
for the next three hours who would you
rather read
bentham or mill style-wise
what is your hobson's choice for them
it's really yeah it could be about pain
pains right i mean i would think it
would be milk because mill
doesn't provide you with these
interminable lists that seem to go on
forever
and try to cover every single
possibility i hope that you know
mills at least even more interesting too
and yeah we did we last class we
actually
i give them a worksheet by which we
maybe do that
um we we looked at
some bigger picture issues drone strikes
and uh
soda vans um but you know
we've we've got some ways of doing it
for other things so let's respond
so quantitative versus qualitative when
you say quantitative that's measurable
everything is comparable right when we
thought about
measuring pleasure by how much you'd be
willing to pay for it
dollar amounts one dollar is equivalent
to another dollar
right you can swap them back and forth
twenty dollars you can have a twenty
dollar bill you swap
for twenty singles similarly with
pledges and pains you could compare them
against each other quantitatively by
using that hedonic kit
and you know we saw there's some
problems with this some of this seems a
little kind of made up
from time to time but but you know you
can still do it there's certain proxies
like like money that we can use
there's actually fairly sophisticated
theories out there that sometimes get
used in business
for calculating utility qualitative
keyword there is quality right when you
have differences in quality
there are some sorts of breaks
and here's the i mean this doesn't
apply to all of our uses of the term
quality but this is what what mill means
if you have different qualities
different qualitative levels
you go from this level to this level no
amount of this level is going to
get you here something has to change
something has to be fundamentally
different he doesn't actually have this
many different levels
he practically speaking has two levels
i think if we were going to try to make
this work we would have to distinguish
probably more levels and get a bit more
sophisticated
with this that he's doing here
so what are these what are these
different levels of pleasures well you
know the
pleasures that are at the animal
or sensual novel
if we're just staying at that level we
can compare them against each other
we can do the hedonic calculus we can
say
one beer is just as good of a pleasure
as two cups of coffee
for instance you know just based on
taste or
intoxication you know who who knows i
mean i'm kind of making this up as i go
along
um
one hour of
watching you know watching people run
back and forth with the ball
doing some sort of game might be worth
ten boxes of cereal that you like to eat
i don't know you know you can
we can go on with these sort of things
forever that's all at this level
because it has to do with the senses the
pleasures that the
pet pig could could indulge in
but we have higher pleasures and the
reason we have higher pleasures
is we have higher faculties this is what
makes us distinctively human
so i'm going to just you know we don't
have too much time for looking at the
passages very closely but i want to
hit on this he says human beings have
faculties more elevated than the animal
appetites and once made conscious of
them
once made consciousness some people are
not yet conscious of these once made
conscious of them
do not regard anything as happiness
which does not include their
gratification
so here we're at the distinctively
human level
we're talking about higher faculties
but what are these what makes us
i know what knows the answer is and
we'll look at it in a second what makes
us distinctive
as opposed to the other hands what makes
you
qualitatively better than
anything other than a human being
yeah more marines yeah so our brains
and it's interesting to say that because
usually when you talk about somebody
having brains what do we mean
we're thinking about these yeah so if
you use the word introduction you could
use
and we often will say intelligence we
mean something very similar to that
that isn't it that's not everything
that's that's a very important part of
it
what else i mean dog and cat likes to
snuggle with you
and get close and all that but you know
if you're a million you might say that's
physical responses
but you know we form different kinds of
relationships don't we
our affection can be at a higher level
mill talks about our imagination
and our feelings this is the word
feeling
and our what he calls our moral
faculty and what does he mean by our
moral faculty
our sense of right and wrong you know
we've talked about this
many times over the course of the
semester your dog will never ask itself
am i a good dog
it'll look to you to say you know am i a
good dog
meaning do i get the treat you know or
do i get do i get sent outside or
vanished or something like that but it's
never going to actually think to itself
am i a good dog what is what does
goodness mean in my case
and these sort of things that you guys
actually do think about
whether you think about it you know in a
very explicit
conscious way or in a sort of model
muddle your way through a way that's
part of what it means to be used
so having an imagination which allows
for creativity
animals are creative to some degree but
not i mean
they're not making this sort of stuff
right that you're about to
see in just a moment
intellect animals you know they do some
problem solving
not the way we do and these are
pleasurable
they are intellectual pleasures there
are pleasures of the imagination
when you're watching a movie now we have
we have dogs and cats that actually will
watch the screams and they do identify
some things as like other animals and
we'll bark at them or
you know attentively watch them but
they're not getting
you know if we're like last night we
watched the minority report and some of
the sopranos
the dogs are not following the plot
lines
they're not they're not deciding whether
tony soprano made the right choice or
the wrong choice at this time
and they're not going to have a
conversation about it because they
don't have faculties we enjoy doing that
i imagine that for every one of you
there's some television show
or series or something along those lines
that you
want to know what happens next and
you're interested in it and you enjoy
finding that out and thinking about it
right
i would say our appreciation of music
falls in here
now here's the problem mill often seems
to talk
as if
anything that is based in the senses
is merely at this level so when we think
about
i mean he's okay with music right music
you know can elevate us because he had
this very romantic conception of music
going on at the time i think he would be
perfectly willing to say when we're
watching
you know play we're engaging in some
sort of imaginative or intellectual
pleasure but when it comes to food
it seems like well that's just stuff we
shovel on our faces
and it can be you know the taste can be
better or worse
but that's merely at this level this
lower level
it doesn't engage these higher faculties
and every time that i've taught this i
thought well that's kind of weird
you know and i've been teaching this for
a long time so it wasn't you know
it wasn't necessarily having the
culinary institute of america down the
road
which really makes the problem pressing
and i would teach this that i think
well wait a second you know couldn't
food
involve higher pleasures
you know if you think about other
analogs let's say we take for example um
sexuality now if you're just hooking up
with somebody
for the night just to have sex that
probably is just at this level
right and there are some people i
suppose who
you know make some sort of big game out
of it you know they're kind of they're
some sort of connoisseurs or something
like that you know like
you can read these novels um like
dangerous reasons where people are you
know doing all this arrangement but that
sort of
that puts it up at a higher level
becomes a game for them and even that
is kind of you know lacking in what's
available to us in terms of pleasure
if you want to talk about uh intimacy in
a relationship
that's not at this level that's a good
that's at a much higher level one other
concept that's really important before
we
go on to the sort of practical
experiential demonstration who's the
person who gets to decide this
mill talks about somebody being
a judge and i i like the word ideal
judge for this
this is a person who has thoroughly
experienced
both levels of whatever is being
compared they have to
not only experience the higher level but
the lower level they have to
experience the higher level just as much
as the lower level but they have to also
experience the lower level so you could
not be approved
you could not have lived a life that's
solely dedicated to these
these higher things and you've never
actually indulged yourself in just
sheer sensual pleasure having a beard
just for the sake of tasting a beer
you know any of these sorts of things in
order to be able to compare them against
each other
but mill says once you do once you
actually have enough experience in this
sort of stuff
it doesn't matter how much of the lower
pleasure is offered
you'll pass it up for a for a higher
pleasure
you'll say nah i i i
this is not good enough i need this
once you've actually experienced it this
is one of the big problems
though in his time as well as in our
time
many people don't really experience
these
they they don't get to be brought in
contact with these
in his time it was in large part because
of social conditions
in our time that's still an issue but
not as big of an issue
and we ought to think about why it is
that we don't um
that you know why why we don't know
these higher pleasures or appreciate
these higher pleasures
as much as we could now when it comes to
food
we have the culinary right down the road
and
what are they doing there if it's only
about this stuff if it's only this lower
level of pleasure how can there be an
entire institution
devoted to this that you know
ties in all these other studies with the
production
and consumption of food so this is where
i'm going to
actually leave off and chef patel is
going to take over
so i would argue that
if food was not a higher pleasure
the cia would not even exist because
food
is really attainable by people
in other ways you could you could get
food especially here in this country
some people do worldwide you know in
other countries struggle to get food
and that's when i think that eating
in that case is not pleasurable maybe
at all and it kind of i think in a sense
correlates a little bit to the hierarchy
of needs
if you don't have any food i don't know
if you're gonna eat no matter what it is
you're eating
even if it is we would think it's
pleasurable i don't
know if you're gonna find pleasure in it
because you're so
kind of stressed out of maybe where your
next meal is going to come from
that even if it tastes good you might
not that might not even be
what registers in your head at the time
so you're eating strictly for substance
but i can tell you that i believe
food and i think you probably will all
agree
does represent higher pleasures and
could stimulate
a lot of intellectual power and thought
and debate
and um
i'm going to try to illustrate that a
little bit with
with with some food comparisons
but what i i do want to say is i believe
oh i'm sorry
i think i might qualify at this point in
my career
as an ideal judge because i
not only experience food on such a basic
level but also the higher levels in fact
a week from tomorrow i'm gonna i'm
taking my wife to dinner in new york
city
and i'm gonna spend the thousand dollars
for the two of us
to eat dinner and i know people there
but this restaurant's called per se and
i am going there to really experience
very very very maybe almost the the
highest pleasures attainable
by someone when it comes to food and the
reason why i can get even more pleasure
out of it is because i understand it
but that said i being an ideal judge
i get pleasure from food
that other people are eating just for
substance
maybe when i travel i'll give you an
example if i
when i was in thailand i ate some street
food
and i got high pleasure from eating
jasmine rice
there where i don't think the populace
where i was was getting too much
pleasure that was more of a staple
but the fact that i understood
and i had pre-knowledge of the culture
and what that represented
and why it was jasmine rice and the
grain of the rice
and how it was cooked and some of the
aromatics that were infused into the
rice
i got very stimulated
just by eating a little bit of jasmine
rice
so i think it also varies um based on
individuals and individual experience
and your what culture you're coming from
but i would definitely argue that food
represents high pleasure many many times
so let's do a little bit of a comparison
and and maybe we could generate some
some uh conversation
we're gonna start with the the nuts i'm
gonna pass some of these around too
can you eat in the morning
yeah i think for for many of our
students is that they're going to be
their first meal of the day
trust me on the day well what what's
nutritional about nuts
what what nutrition do you have what are
your components you have in there that
are healthy does anybody know
what do you think are they healthy nuts
huh maybe not with all the salt on them
why are they healthy
well they're pretty good source of
protein
they have often monounsaturated fats
that are not really bad for you that are
good right
a little some fiber they're not
unhealthy
in fact they're probably a good snack
because they're low carbs right and they
fill you up because they're a higher
level of protein
so i try to snack on nuts now obviously
you can look at me and say the sky
cheats i definitely cheat along
but what i'd like you to do what we have
there is
try the peanuts first those are planters
dry roasted peanuts
anything special about them unless you
have peanut allergy don't please eat
them
any anything special about them do you
get pleasure
by eating them or is it just they taste
okay but it's like
very pedestrian no
yes yeah now try
the other nuts and tell me what you
sense are they good
what makes them good
a foreign taste reminds her what's your
name
ariel reminds ariel of
an indian culture so how about anybody
else
what else do you notice eating those
ariel woke up when she ate those and got
pretty
got a little excited about that not when
she's eating the peanuts not at the
prospect of
plants but at the of eating those mixed
nuts
what else do you notice about those nuts
well i think it's just because there's
like
i'm so used to the other regular nuts
that when i tasted that like flavored
pot
so it was different the flavor popped it
was different so it sparked your
curiosity
did you find yourself saying oh what's
in there
did you find yourself trying to identify
what not is what
did you find yourself thinking globally
he did about another culture what's in
it did anybody try to distinguish
anything about the spices themselves
yes or no did anybody think that what is
it that i'm tasting
it's basically curry powder but curry
powder is a mixture of spices including
turmeric coriander cumin fenugreek
right star and east possibly so it's all
these mixtures of spices that come
together
and form this complex yes married kind
of flavor
so i think that example alone
just um kind of brought it up to a
higher
level because you tried to you know
analyze it
you made global references
you understood that this represented
something cultural or cross-cultural
right what kind of nuts are in there
cashews cashes
what else
i'm afraid to guess again no are there
hazelnuts in there hazelnuts or
filaments as they're sometimes called
which are domestic cashews come from
rainforest
there's macadamia nuts in there that
come from these trees indigenous of
australia but
often grown in hawaii right there's
almonds
california almonds but they grow in
pretty much you know like the
mediterranean middle east
but what you also have represented in
that little cup
is food globalization those products are
coming from everywhere
and you have a contrast of textures now
there's a lot to think about there
there's a lot
that we just talked about with those
simple little curry nuts
but let me ask you something don't you
have if you went to a restaurant
and you had a cocktail at the bar
and instead of the peanuts that you find
at a bar often
while you're waiting for your table
there were those curry mixed nuts
would you also have a higher perception
of value
for the would you would you think of the
establishment and now in a different
light
so i mean it is really food is affecting
you in many many different ways
the second the second example we have
here
we have two chilled soups these are not
vegetarian they are made both of them
have a little chicken stock in them
so just to let you know if you're veg
and there's a little dairy
as well so just to let you know other
than that there's no pork products
there's no
other animal products in there but i'm
not going to tell you
what the garnish one is
but just i'm sorry that's okay but
visually you see that they're different
you have this white
liquid and then you have a liquid that
has some visual appeal i mean granted
it's
it would be a lot nicer looking if it
was in a ceramic bowl
and you know a little cleaned up but you
get the drift right
so which one they're both pretty similar
color
if when you looked at them did you
automatically gravitate towards the
garnish one
and what did you start to think about
what were you thinking when there's a
cool green color well what else did you
think about that
did you think about what those things
were yeah do you need an explanation
yes you do you do you want that green
stuff is
what's telling the green liquid i'll
tell you in a bit okay
i'd like you to taste the no taste the
white one first
oh you did okay taste the white one
first
are you gonna have it afterwards
and tell me what you think is it good
this is a preparation that dates back to
mill's time
so this could be honestly what
mill ate at some point
what do you think it is it tastes like
potato leeks something
it's it's called vichy suas which is
potato leek soup
a chilled potato and leek soup so you
have onion flavor
but it's more or less pretty you liked
it a lot i could say
it pretty much has a neutral flavor it's
not that
descript right but it's tasty enough
when you eat that is that sort of like
would you say more about low pleasure
i mean it feels good what do you think i
think it complements well with that
okay we'll start garnishing it
what do you think is it high pleasure
are you really or it's kind of singular
in flavor it's interesting
but i would say once you understand a
little more about food
this would be something that is is good
and you think it tastes pretty good but
it's it's
more or less substance i mean it's not
something you have on a regular basis
but quite frankly if you lived in an
area where you know you grew both only
potatoes and onions you probably would
have this a lot
this would be your equivalent of
porridge or something that you know
would be become a staple
so would be really substantial very low
pleasure
now if you taste the other one
you're expecting that it's the same with
garnish right
it looks almost the same but with
garnish
but it's not so what is your brain
telling you here anything does it you
have any questions
besides what's the green stuff it's good
do you any questions
i think the question is the same for a
lot of us
the green stuff is chive oil
so it's olive french olive oil on you
french extra virgin olive oil infused
with fresh chives
and then it's allowed to just decant and
strain out so all the pulp stays behind
and some of the essential oils from the
chives are
kind of emulsified but what's the the
base what's the soup there
does it do it doesn't taste like the
potato leak right
i don't think any of you will be able to
identify it who could identify what that
is
no right so that
really is making you think what at least
it would for me
what is it what is it i need to know i
get i need to know because i don't eat
food just for some
oh no that's not true i'll go home you
know hungry one night after a couple of
beers and throw down a frozen taco yeah
or something like that
in that substance but most of the time
i'm interested in everything i'm eating
and i'm dissecting it
and actually trying to definitely
go to higher pleasures higher intellect
and incorporating everything here
intellect imagination
feeling and moral
faculties as well and let me tell you
how that applies
and then i'll tell you what the rest of
it is
intellect goes back to what you were
saying ariel in my opinion what is this
what culture is it from i'm trying to
learn from my food experience
feeling or imagination
a lot of times we have we look at food
the presentation
and we try to manipulate the
presentation and create
something that's very art artistic and
something that transforms the food
into something that stimulates the
imagination a presentation that
stimulates the imagination
feeling think about comfort food think
about that hot
that excuse me that cold winter day
where you go home and you have like a
nice stew
or or a soup or where you're you're kind
of sick and you have
chicken soup i mean you're getting
definitely
feelings out of that feelings of comfort
soothing
right and moral faculty well we talked a
little bit about that earlier where is
this food coming from
who does it impact i think about that
i have a i have i think about if i'm
buying asparagus in february
i think about well where's that coming
from who's it
impacting people take a lot of our
students take
some pretty radical stance when it comes
to
food issues like gmos genetically
modified organisms
or engineering local
versus food that's transported with what
they feel is a large global
organic versus conventional all these
things go through your mind
but it's very complicated i mean you
could say oh we don't want genetically
engineered food but with this growing
population
that's scheduled to reach you know 10
billion really soon
how are we going to feed the world well
we have enough food but can we
distribute it is it better to
genetically engineer
corn so we could grow it in the desert
i'm not sure
what the answer is when it comes to food
my example of asparagus being brought up
from peru
in the winter here if you say no
we're going to just eat asparagus in may
and june when it's local here
that's all well and good but what
happens to the farmers in peru
do they now grow something illicit
because they
their economy depends so much on that
agricultural product
i'm not sure i'm just saying it's pretty
complicated
and every time i make a food choice i
think of these things
what you're eating is a puree it's made
in the same technique as the potato leek
soup but it's made with
jerusalem artichokes or sunchokes
anybody ever have that
that's not just now and then there are
you know regular artichokes
logo artichokes yeah those i cleaned
shaved on the slicer and deep fried them
as a garnish
now jerusalem artichokes just so that
you know are tubers that are not related
to artichokes they're
actually related to sunflowers and they
grow locally
you could i mean i grow them at home
they just you plant them they just start
growing and growing and you weed them
out a little bit to get them to grow to
a
edible point but they're a tuber
you know tuber like a potato kind of
starchy
and all but they have if you notice they
have a very distinct flavor and
if you're not used to that that's a food
i think that you'd say
what the hell is this you know what is
it it's not easily identifiable unless
somebody teaches you
and then you you know like i just told
you it's a member of the sunflower
family you could grow it here it's an
indigenous product there's so much to
know behind it
that as humans we can process
as animals we're much less discriminate
about food
but they do make choices right your dogs
and cats won't eat everything
even if it's safe they might not eat
everything
they do make choices but not based on
the same
not based on pleasure based on i think
i'm not a dog hopefully maybe in the
past life
future life hopefully i i think it's
good life
but
i mean i don't think they're really
getting pleasure they're eating because
they know that they need to eat where's
their next meal going to come from
i have a very nervous cat that just
constantly wants to eat because i think
she's afraid that food's going to run
out
so that's why they're eating i'm not
eating that
people do eat that way globally
sometimes though also
so it all depends on your socioeconomic
situation
questions anything to go along with that
no am i catching the essence of
you are you think yeah what do you think
joe
i think so you know just like there's
certain like
i i'm gonna use there's certain stories
that we connect with food that's not
happening on the animal level
and i don't mean stories in the sense
that you know they're made up or
something but some of the connections
might be like intellectual so that by
eating
the jerusalem artichoke i know that it's
you know a member of the sunflower
family or what have you but there's also
even like to say cultural connections or
familial collections
and you know like so you know i have a
dog and
you know i'm reading the package on the
dog food
you know whatever origin dog food we're
buying and i'm from canada and it comes
from canada
i'm making all these connections but to
be honest my dog doesn't give a rat's
ass where this food's coming from and so
there's that
you know if the idea then is connecting
up with greg is talking about
layered on top of just the pure physical
chewing and the digesting and the
tasting of the food there's this kind of
like say
cerebral aspect to it as well
such that we can talk about a higher
pleasure
you know a mill sense of a higher
pleasure of eating
as opposed to looking at it
in utilitarian terms like in the bad
sense of utility
right but yeah i agree yeah
and like i said in the beginning the cia
would not exist
if not for um food being pleasurable
because
although you could argue that there are
especially when it comes to we divide
food service into commercial and
non-commercial
here at marist you have food service
right you have cafeterias
other types of dining catering that goes
on
this is non-commercial type food service
because the primary business of of
marist is education but yet
food is a necessary function you have to
have food here
it's because we need food so
yes there is non-commercial food service
but would you be happy if there was a
connection
i mean this direct definition that
non-commercial
food service was utilitarian
and just gave you know all you had to
eat down there
was basically food that would keep you
going and give you energy
don't you want variety don't you want
interesting food
don't you want rotating menus don't you
get pissed all the time
at the food service and say hey man you
know this is terrible or can't you just
change this up
or i'm sick of lucky charms can you get
golden grahams
who knows i i mean yeah i've heard it
all right
so even in a non-commercial sense when
food is not the primary business
like a restaurant or food service at a
hotel or a banquet hall
people want variety and want it to be a
higher pleasure
can you can you tell them a little bit
about how culinary students
are trained to become ideal judges yeah
you know that was interesting because i
was thinking about that
and i was thinking that actually i wrote
down
a note about that let me just pull that
out because i kind of thought that
that i kind of thought of perspectives
students
are a bad judge and i thought that
current students are kind of a bad judge
but that
faculty and industry leaders are good
judge but then
the ideal judge would be somebody who
actually went through that whole
kind of range but
i think that the students through
pallet development that you mentioned
and
education in terms of the cult the
cultures
and the in greek information about
agriculture and ingredients
and all that they become a good judge
and they become a good judge when they
really experience
low pleasure food and then they're able
to elevate that food
into kind of a higher
realm for i'll give you an example rice
we talked about
you have steamed rice or you could have
risotto with fontina cheese
pancetta and brussels sprouts leaves you
know with
really unbelievable aged
cheese grated on top made really well i
mean it's still a
dough bowl of rice but i'll pay 30.
i know what it costs and it doesn't cost
a lot to put that on the plate
but i as a professional will pay 30 for
that without blinking a knife it's made
correctly
because i'm paying for the care and the
love and the skill that went into that
but i think that's what that's kind of
what happens to students and then
only through experience and learning
what happens is
when when you're a culinary student you
learn how to
prepare these all this for all these
preparations baking
culinary depends what you do you learn
the business behind it
but it's not until you're doing these
tasks daily
repetitively that you start to recognize
the little nuances that are involved
and i think it's the un like being able
to understand the properties
and how things react and actually
anticipate
how food is evolving either in the plate
on the pot that makes you you know a
better
judge quite honestly
how long do you think it takes i mean
the the two-year program and the
four-year program
how long do you think it takes to really
become a great judge of
i think it varies depending on on
what you're coming in with and then what
your experience is after
how much of an immersion experience you
have
and then if it's really focused or
restricted but yet
immersed yes you may be an ideal judge
in some areas but not overall
so i think if you're if you're talking
about
being an ideal judge in a general sense
it probably takes longer because it's
much broader and you have to experience
so much more
but i think that somebody could become
an ideal judge if they're focused on
something specific
or something just less
broad like if somebody just for instance
is a film right now called uh
it's sort of a documentary i didn't see
it but i know of it has anybody seen
jiro dreams of sushi
i know that i haven't seen it i know the
movie you've seen it
no top movie on netflix queue
yeah so jiro dreams sushi this guy jiro
in tokyo evidently
has a little sushi shop that's near a
train station
and it's considered a mecca
yes like the sushi of all sushis you go
there you never want to eat it
again i believe that but that's all this
guy has done
his whole life is devoted to sushi and
his family
so he is he he is the
ideal judge for sushi
ask him to make meatloaf it's going to
be challenging
right so i think you know
it all depends how long it would take
depends on
where you're focusing okay does that
make
sense yeah by the way i
i ate sushi at six o'clock in the
morning at the tsukiji fish market in
tokyo
about 10 years ago and when i love sushi
the sashimi you guys
yes and when i came back here
to the states i could not eat it for a
year
i just because like i seek out optimum
food experiences optimum like when i was
in
mexico city i'm just eating at these i'm
trying to find these little hole on
walls
where i could get the best chicharron
the best tacos al pastor
when i'm in puerto rico i'm down at uh
pinones this little area that's like
you know all street food trying to get
the best bakala ito
and you know what i'm saying and
everywhere i go
i'm seeking out that optimum food
experience
which most people might see at a lower
level
there people that are used to it but i
see it as the pinnacle
the highest level because i i so wanna
i continually wanna build up my
expertise
right that i seek out those experiences
learn everything there is what's the
history behind that
there's so much history in the in in all
this food
i just want to know about it i have a
book called the literary gourmet the
first recipe
from abraham's time like jacob and esau
and like
way way back in the bible is this potage
of red lentils
that has water red lentils and a lamb
bone in it
and to me i would love to have that
prepared for me
that would give me so much stimulation
appeal to my highest senses that i could
experience a dish from biblical times
in the most authentic know i get a
little into it
i'm going to chill now i know it's
friday it's for spring break
anything else any other comments
what about your food experiences do you
share anybody share any of that
experience
what what have you experienced i mean
not particularly like the mind but you
definitely
like this being awesome but when you
travel you have to try and improve
right those don't and does it
does it have do you have it categorized
in any way or it could just happen right
yeah i mean i don't know food the way
you do so it's not as easy for me to
just
identify that right but
even so there are probably times where
unexpected unexpectedly
something is and this might not even be
completely conscious but something might
taste some so good and be complex enough
that subconsciously you're
regarding all of these things cultural
what is in there
what's this contrast of texture and it's
higher levels of pleasure
and it's interesting how our
as we get older and certain physio
physiological changes happen
how your how pleasure is ranked
differently like you know quite honestly
you know when i was your age sex was
number one
my greatest pleasure my greatest goal
it is now sleep okay
so sleep if i could get a good night's
sleep i'll pass sex up
no problem if you admire at your age
that would never happen i could be up 48
hours
i would never turn it down and i
got it and i thought about where i was
getting it next just
soon after so but so
i think where we find these highest
pledges do
to shift along the way also
yes it may not be the same but you know
um you know like i'm just thinking of
like children and how they're educated
and so part of it is you know like so
all of you guys here too right you would
have done music appreciation classes
right so your little kids they expose
you to classical music
and it may just sound like you know
noise or whatever or
art movements and impressionism but
there's not really an equivalent for
food right so
you know my children will be taught
nutrition but
you know they're not taught to say
discriminate between like a
good tomato and a bag of tomato yeah so
it's something to wear like if it's
going back to that line for mill where
this happens when you're made conscious
of them
it seems that oftentimes in our society
we're not made
conscious of these things or you know
unless it's done kind of informally but
there's not say like a kind of emphasis
in our society towards
you know what what constitutes you know
not necessarily like what's uh
like a nutritious food but you know what
constitutes a good salad
in the aesthetic sense or what
constitutes a good burger
you know you're right yeah you're right
and you can have it all
you know i mean you're not going to give
up the nutrition and oftentimes they
probably go together right yes yes
you know you can even make an argument
that if you just teach
nutrition on that kind of level you know
something could be nutritious but tastes
like crap and so
um but you know like if it's a case
where you're you're
you're you're getting at the nutrition
through
the taste of the food you know we might
be it might be more effective
pedagogically to maybe expose kids to
delicious foods that happen to be
nutritious rather than just teach them
nutrition and then they're just like
well this is
all bad undoubtedly i mean that's
right and that's where i think
there are a lot of efforts emerging to
not only educate um young people
you younger than you about nutritional
foods what's
nutrition but with right how to make
them either delicious
or actually train school
food service providers on how to make it
delicious yeah they're they were
actually getting to like the
part of you know mill about so many
people are deprived of the
the chance to experience the higher
pleasures if you think about
we do teach about food in our our
elementary schools but we teach in a
very negative way
by giving them in a lot of cases you
know pretty bad food yeah
you know and we said well this is it you
know and i remember when i was a kid
um it was pizza burgers and pizzas those
were the like the two greatest things
you know yeah instead of having the
salisbury steak that we would get that
was
you know pretty pretty awful and you
know i look at the stuff that we
we would eat that that pizza that was
not good pizza
but you know for us that was that was as
good as it was going to get and so
because we didn't know any better you
know right there wasn't anything fresh
but even so i don't think you i think
you were eating on much of a lower
pleasure exactly yeah
no matter what even if you didn't know
better if it's not good
it's low pleasure yeah even if it's the
best available
but when you do have the elevation
that will that distinguishes the lower
and higher pleasure
so that's an interesting i think thought
too but when it comes to
um teaching out our kids now
even even if they're not getting this at
home
i still think in school if they're
exposed to more nutritious
foods they're going to pick up some of
these habits or at least have more to
think about and re
build on their reasoning skills when it
comes to food choices i think it's
extremely important
that we keep moving in that direction
even at the cia we have a health and
wellness initiative
we're trying even in our courses to
incorporate more whole grains lots more
plant-based food shrink
portions of protein you know this is
it's a problem
it's a problem out there and i know i
over
indulge i take in too many and i
exercise
is a lot so i mean i have endurance i
mean i could go and
do a 40 mile bike ride or whatever i
mean without
a problem it's just that i over indulge
it's
too much opportunity for me to consume
and
i have to do it for evaluation purposes
as well give them give them an idea
about how much tasting
students would be doing at the culinary
well you know we encourage them to taste
more than often they do
i mean you you guys you know young
people
their taste buds are more sensitive as
we get older our taste
sense tastes kind of gets a little we
lose taste buds and
and we out taste changes i mean i
i crave bitter how many of you like
really bitter like broccoli rob
i didn't like this when i was your age
at all
but i craved that now and that's just a
change i crave less sweets you know
and much more acidic food
so you know those things do change and
so the students have definitely more
sensitized palettes
so a lot of times they they're very
they're all leery to taste everything
but that's such a big part of the
process the educational process
and um i've even been working with we
have kosher students that can't taste
anything
because we're not coach we don't have
kosher facilities and what we've
tried to do with them i've gotten them
pots and i've worked on a program where
they could cook their own food getting
so this way they could simulate what
they're learning in the classroom
and be able to taste it even if they're
making it but they have a point of
comparison
which is really key we have students
with allergies
and we have to hold them still
accountable for preparing you know in
the same standards as other students
to when it comes to assessment of taste
or balance or
contrast we're always looking to balance
food on a plate
contrast colors textures a mouth
feel right and contrast the basic taste
sweet bitter sour salty
and umami you guys know mommy
at all anybody over here umami
it's kind of the savory taste of protein
it's mostly
uh kind of illustrated if you eat like
shiitake mushrooms or even ketchup
and tomatoes or that taste of of like
grilled steak
it's kind of it's a little less um
tangible per se but it is definitely
there it's actually
msg you know msg monosodium glutamate
that is concentrated umami and i'm not
condoning
that you eat that or anything there's a
lot of glutamates
or related compounds in naturally
occurring foods
in fact monosodium glutamate is a
naturally
natural derived product i mean it's it's
a refined
it's refined from sugar beets or other
veg plant products so it's not as bad as
people
really think it is but
any any other questions or any
curiosities about
food or anything what yes this could be
totally unrelated
but it means this thing is or asked
absolutely
when you were talking about the cat and
how it's eaten
for sustenance your cat eats crazy
like he's not going to have another meal
for days my cat
has been like that since he was born
yeah mine too
he's about two years old now and he
still runs
and dogs the whole plate oh and now it's
two bowls
don't know why you've been doing this
but we feed them every
few hours it's not like the start yeah i
know i know it's like we leave food
there because we're leaving for the day
and before we even get out the door
yeah i know evidently there's some cats
like that
but i might have one that does the same
same thing
she's like a dog she don't go anywhere
she follows my father-in-law
to the garden it's like it's kind of a
dog in a cat's body but you know it's
funny you were making these comparisons
craig
i always say it's like it's about you
know capability
and i don't think we also have unlimited
capability
i think that we're restricted as
organisms too yeah with comprehension or
even the ability to have
certain pleasures i mean we're probably
restricted in
in some way just we have we might be the
the one life form here on earth that
could reason
and and change
and and affect so much change around us
and do and use resources way too fast
but
i do think we have some limitations too
even when it comes to
creativity and some of the senses as
well
i mean look at how it's unfortunate for
example
that a dog does not have the ability to
be more dis
um uh selective when it comes to foods
because i think they're such
they have such a greater sense of smell
yeah that they would actually probably
really enjoy
food a lot more they could taste it
better smell it better
but they don't have the brain power to
make those choices yeah
i mean i have a story but just to turn
so i have chickens
and uh and they're totally not they'll
need anything
but um there's a i'm on a chicken blog
so like there's a
like you know chicken discussion group
and there was a woman
uh who was making like uh homemade food
for her chickens
i just kind of give them the pellets i
buy from the agricultural supply store
but she got rid of her chickens because
she would make them this like kale salad
or whatever and
the chicken they'll poop on their food
they have no
they'll just keep on eating it and it's
so disgusted her
that she went to the blanks to make this
homemade food
and she thought the chickens were making
like a more like a statement this is
you know and she says i'm not keeping it
totally disgusting but
it's something like i you know even
lower than dogs or whatever but
you just kind of see where they're just
eating through pure sustenance like
there's no
you know there's i'm not sure if they're
discriminating anything because
you know they're just they're chickens
right yeah but you know we benefit
sometimes because
uh chickens that have a diverse diet
take
all right their much better than that
right so my you know my chicken's free
range or whatever
so the yolks are you know it's orange
more delicious
i mean and this is something because i i
get
my my neighbor has a farm with chickens
and i get
fresh eggs cookies eggs duck eggs
chicken eggs i eat them all
right even my 11 year old son will eat
goose eggs
really good makes great creme brulee the
yolks
by the way the best creme brulee ever
but
i when i get these eggs fresh if i cook
one of these eggs just in a tiny bit of
butter
just with salt and pepper i get more
pleasure out of eating that
than i would like some kind of fancy
meal that
really gives me pleasure because i know
what
utilitarian eggs are
and i know what they are i've eaten them
i've used them they're so
important in cooking and baking i mean
eggs eggs eggs they do everything
they're most amazing food but when i
have these eggs
that have so much flavor subtle flavors
it really really satisfies me i mean i i
celebrate that meal
you guys think i'm crazy
i don't blame you
any other questions for chef mattel
let's let's give him a hand